thank you very much for being with us
and can you just explain how and why you
decided to quit the government yeah we
were heading towards these votes on
alternatives I'd been a very strong
supporter of the primaries withdrawal
agreement and I continue to support it
and I voted for it last Friday Minister
or not but I became very concerned that
if it didn't get through we needed an
alternative and my colleagues had to be
free to vote for that alternative
otherwise a parliamentary vote on an
alternative didn't mean very much and I
wasn't certain that would be the case I
wasn't certain that Oliver lemons
amendment would get through and I felt I
had to vote for it and I was also
conscious that other of my colleagues
were doing the work to create
alternatives and I wasn't and I felt it
was time to to do that but I still want
to see the withdrawal agreement go
through but if not because I'm concerned
about No Deal I want to make sure
there's an alternative available from
your conversations with the Prime
Minister and you've had lots of them I
mean you went to checkers the day before
you resigned and to talk with the Prime
Minister and you worried that she might
try and go for a no deal brexit if her
deal doesn't get through the perhaps has
always been pretty clear that that
really isn't her option she's very
concerned about the State of the Union
and what a No Deal brexit would mean in
relation to that not least in relation
to Ireland and she's been pretty clear
about that however I'm also very
conscious that she's under huge pressure
from some in the cabinet and others who
see no deal as the the way for the
United Kingdom to leave and the Prime
Minister needs to know that there are
colleagues who don't agree with that the
colleagues who were prepared to be as
committed as some of our No Deal
colleagues to prevent this and that we
have to find the compromise I voted to
remain in the European Union I'm not a
remainer now I spent my time in the
house command since the referendum
voting to leave because I think that's
the right thing for the United Kingdom
so I've compromised to a degree and I've
said this to my colleagues we're looking
for more compromise from them if the
country is going to get through this
so do you think there are other members
the cabinet are the ministers who are
willing to resign from the government to
try and stop a new deal how many do you
think there are there are I'm not going
to put any number on it but that really
shouldn't be in a way what we're talking
about resigning from the government is
not a it's not a great thing to do and
I'm sorry that I had to do it there's
been a lot of people but ultimately you
have to have a government it's got to
keep functioning it's got to keep
running the country and we're doing a
lot of things besides concentrating on
brexit I don't want to see more
resignations my colleagues and I want to
see a situation in which we've made an
agreement and and we've done what we
think the British people have wanted to
do which is leave the EU but leave on
good terms these are our partners these
are our colleagues and friends in the
European Union the way the debate is
gone has been to separate us from our
our partners and turn them into our
enemies and we we are at peril from this
I spent enough time in conflict areas
over the last few years to know how
fragile peace and security is you can
pull a thread
and before you know where you are things
have got very very difficult we shall be
looking to partner with our friends
leave on good terms and leave with good
terms for the future relationships and
that's what I hope colleagues will still
compromise on doing I don't want to see
more resignations I mean talking about
the fragility there of nations around
the world I mean are you really worried
about the future of the UK if people
feel that brexit has gone wrong and I do
worry
I think like many colleagues and like
both Lisa and Emily have spoken about on
the program before there's a greater
polarization in politics than ever
before and that polarization has turned
not into debate where you recognize the
strength of an opponent's argument and
you move to overcome it but you start to
feel there's nothing whatsoever good in
what someone else is putting to you and
that's very dangerous and we've seen in
in other countries that very quickly if
people become so polarized they can't
accept an argument on the other side you
know people start to resort to different
methods now it hasn't happened here and
when I've been going around the world
although people are puzzled about us
leaving Europe they have commented about
the strength of our democracy and how
we've been able to have these arguments
but I'm very conscious and one of the
reasons I voted to remain in the
European Union was we've had you know
seventy years of peace since the end of
the Second World War in Europe and these
things are held together by
multinational relationships and
institutions now if we're going to leave
the EU and it's perfectly possible to do
so without everything fracturing we
should do it in a way that ensures that
relationships continue and continue to
be strong and I think we have to be very
careful about how we do these things and
how we debate and argue with each other
I've been talking about the kind of
polarization of the debate the the lack
of ability of people to compromise don't
let grief your colleague who backs a
second referendum and lost a confidence
motion and his conservative Association
this week and you tweeted to say where
on earth are we heading with situations
like this where are we heading and I was
extremely disappointed with the
resulting in Dominic's constituency now
there appears to be a situation where
people have quotes rejoined quotes the
Conservative Party because they've been
belonging to another like you Kipp and
they're setting about some of my
colleagues I must say I don't notice the
reverse and conservatives who voted to
remain and not ganging up on colleagues
who have resolutely refused to to leave
or being the hardliners in order to
remove them there's no remain of force
getting together to seek these elections
we want a broad church in the
Conservative Party I want in it I value
colleagues like Jacob Riis Mark and
Steve Baker who have very strong
principles and work the other way I want
to be part of a Conservative Party that
includes those views and I hope they
want to be part of a Conservative Party
that includes outstanding individuals
like Dominic who have given great
service the country as Attorney General
and as Minister and we've got to work
very hard to find this way through if we
don't if our associations become more
polarized and mine has been terrific
with me it's recognized what I voted for
is recognized what I've been trying to
do
since that vote to ensure that United
Kingdom leaves the EU in a decent way
and most associations I think are
actually full of people like that and
we've got to make sure that the
Conservative Party stays broaden its
membership very broad in those who
support and vote for us which is why
we've got to get on with looking to the
future and start tackling other issues
that people feel are very important the
United Kingdom and keep as many people
on board as possible political parties
are Fran child too and we shouldn't
forget that they can vary it the things
can very easily fall apart we should
fight hard to keep the broad nature of
our political parties both the Labour
Party and Conservative Party for fear
that they become more fractured more
polarized which I don't think will do
the country any good and just finally
before we let you go and there's lots of
rumors in Westminster about the
possibility of a snap general election
if there is a general election should
Tories may lead the Conservative Party
into it well firstly I'm we're all with
Brenda from Bristol on this oh no not
another one I don't see a general
election now adding to the mix that were
in at the moment as anything that would
be likely to be helpful to the country
whoever leads the Conservative Party or
whoever leads the Labour Party or anyone
else at the moment we're not in a phase
for that we need to stick to to this
task that we have in relation to
European Union that settle that and then
move forward offer the public the wide
range of choices that political parties
do that's the best route forward not to
worry about an immediate general
election or who leads anybody let's get
on with doing this job in the first
place nicely dodged should Therese may
lead the party into the general election
the Prime Minister has already said that
she's expecting to leave after we get
the the first stage of brexit going
through I don't anticipate a general
election before that is done okay so
probably the answer would be no